Hey there sleepy heads, Julia here for Dnews.
According to the National Sleep Foundation
snoring affects 90 million Americans.
So you’re probably not the only one sleeping
on the couch tonight.
When you sleep most of your muscles relax.
Including those in your mouth, throat and
airways.
If these become too relaxed, they can get
in the way of your breathing.
As you try to suck more air through the narrowed
airways, these muscles can vibrate, making
sounds like an airplane or lawnmower.
Although it might be annoying to your sleeping
buddy, snoring seems mostly harmless.
Yet several studies linked the night time
malady to some pretty nasty healthy effects.
One study published in the journal Laryngoscope,
found that snoring might lead to a thickening
of the arteries in the heart.
Snoring can also lead to headaches and even
decline in memory.
Not to mention if you wake up your partner,
snoring could get you into some relationship
trouble.
But is your snoring so bad you wake yourself
up?
You might suffer from sleep apnea.
Half of those 90 million I mentioned earlier
might be suffering from Obstructive Sleep
Apnea (OSA).
Apnea means literally “without breath”.
Like the name suggests, this type of sleep
disorder can cause the airways to completely
close.
Sufferers actually stop breathing when they
sleep!
This lack of oxygen wakes people up with a
snort or gasp.
While waking up a bunch of times in the middle
of the night leaves you tired the day, Sleep
Apnea can also lead to a host of other problems.
One large study was published in the journal
American Journal of Respiratory and Critical
Care Medicine.
The study found that patients with severe
apnea have a 30% higher risk of developing
diabetes than those with almost no apnea.
And patients with mild or moderate apnea had
a 23% increased risk of developing diabetes.
Another study published in the journal Journal
of Clinical Sleep Medicine surveyed a group
of patients for 20 years!
The researchers found that, even after controlling
for smoking and other lifestyle factors, people
with moderate to severe obstructive sleep
apnea were four times more likely to die,
nearly four times more likely to have a stroke,
three times more likely to die from cancer,
and 2.5 times more likely to develop cancer.
Lack of oxygen to the brain is never a good
thing.
One study published in the journal Cerebral
Blood Flow and Metabolism, found that the
immediate effects of sleep apnea on the brain
were similar to the effects of a stroke!
Okay okay, have I scared you enough?
Sorry about that.
So currently one of the best treatments for
sleep apnea remains the cumbersome CPAP machine.
CPAP stands for "continuous positive airway
pressure".
Basically, if you can’t guess from that
name, the machine creates pressure on your
airways so those soft tissues don’t get
in the way of your breathing.
The exact pressure depends on the patient
and decided by a physician.
But you breathe easier and pretty much stop
snoring.
While the whole get-up includes a face mask,
that goes into your nose and over your head,
it definitely helps.
Some studies published in the journal Sleep
found that using a CPAP machine improves blood
pressure and even restores brain tissue after
a year of use!
So while it might be awkward, it could actually
add years to your life.
So wanna found out if your snoring is dangerous
or just dang annoying?
Well there’s an app for that, designed by
researchers at the University of Washington.
ApneaApp uses sound waves to monitor breathing.
The app acts kind of like a bat, emitting
sonar to track breathing patterns.
According to its makers, the app can detect
sleep apnea as well as hospital tests 98%
of the time.
The app is only designed for use on android
phones.
Sorry hipsters, you’ll just have to wait.
We talk about sleep a lot on DNews - for instance,
did you know anxiety messes with your sleep?
Check out this video Amy did.